Paul tu dois passer à l'étape suivante de ton
parcours
une puissance incroyable t'attend justice
est sur le point d'être rendue
nous aurons deux plateaux justice plantes
tigresse tu veux un supplément de sauce avec
ça elle le veut de ce côté du
côté du côté si tu  fais seulement ce que tu
peux faire tu ne seras jamais plus que tu
es maintenant j'aime qui je suis tu ne sais même
pas qui tu es
je cherche mon fils comment savons-nous
cela même lié à toi c'est comme
regarder dans un  gros miroir viens à la maison avec
moi salut je suis Amy
tu dois redécouvrir ce que c'est d'être un
pendentif voilà le maître de la douleur la
bête de la vengeance figure les veuves à la maison d'
accord je travaillais avec qui la lame tu
dois sauver un bois il n'y a aucun moyen  Je peux
m'arrêter à moins que tu n'aies ta propre armée
tu ne connais même pas le kungfu alors tu
nous apprendras que ça allait être facile
fou je vais te transformer et ça se
réalisera maîtres
l'escadron de boulettes prendra position
ici à mon signal  l'escadron de nouilles
regarde c'est l'endroit où d'accord j'ai vu
ce genre de  c'était celui destiné
à m'arrêter épargnez-moi le bavardage je
vais prendre votre chat chat chat chat
chat dans le rêve était Kung Fu Panda 3 maître
armure de combat de rhinocéros volants et ce que cela
fait je devrais le tirer je pense que je viens de faire
pipi un  Petit